many states loosening restrictions
health officials are worried about
another wave of infection
spreading across this country the worst
outbreak right now is in the state of
michigan
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in lansing that's the state
capitol with more on the story david
good morning what is happening there
good morning gail just when you think
we're ending the pandemic getting close
to the end up pops michigan here with
another wave and you know this wave is
not being driven by elderly people
it's being driven by infections among
younger people in fact half the folks
here at this hospital in lansing
are under the age of 60.
it definitely feels like deja vu all
over again you know
but again we know what to do dr meredith
hill is the medical director of the
emergency department
and she says that experience is making a
big difference here at sparrow hospital
which is nearing capacity yet again we
are
running probably 95 96 right now
now michigan's test positivity rate is
over 17 percent
compared with nearly 4 just a month ago
there's obviously more community spread
right now it could be because of the
variants that are out there the schools
are going back into session
sports teams lesser restrictions
michigan's department of health says
more than
40 percent of the new outbreaks are tied
to youth sports
and k-12 schools what's the average age
of the person coming in infected now
we're seeing younger and younger
patients um
in their anywhere from you know 20s 30s
through their 60s
on average cases right now are the
highest among those 10 years old to 29
and they're the lowest for those 70 and
older most people who've been vaccinated
so far
i was in rough shape couldn't breathe
coughing nonstop
patient scott neiswanger is only 39. he
says his whole family got coveted after
his son may have been infected at
daycare
just feels like somebody was sitting on
my chest 500 pound guys sit on my chest
and i just couldn't push them off
that was their breaking point just this
week michigan said anyone 16 years or
older can now be vaccinated
we met robert gannon before he went in
to visit his 77 year old mother kia who
was on a ventilator right now
in the icu due to coven had she been
vaccinated
she was not vaccinated i think she was
being hesitant just wanting to see how
things played
out have you been vaccinated i have not
what would it take for you to get
vaccinated
i'd want to make sure that it's safe
look we know there are people like
robert out there who think that so know
this
there have been more than 167 million
vaccines given
in this country clinical trials show
vaccines to be safe with generally mild
side effects
and anytime a death or a hospitalization
is reported after someone
receives the vaccine the cdc always
investigates and i want to read you this
quote because it's very important
a review of all available clinical
information
including death certificates autopsy and
medical records reveal
no evidence that vaccination contributed
to patient deaths tony the science is
very clear david thank you very much